[Music]
Howard Cosell I don't know how many
young people out there familiar with
Howard Cosell but when I was growing up
he was yeah he was the face of most
sporting events I mean it was football
was heavyweight fighting yeah he was
everywhere he was this iconic figure you
got to know him a little bit not at me
you were quite young I did and he was
already established as you know he was
simultaneously this almost cartoonish
television personality but a great
journalist who would address the sports
issues of the day in a way that most of
his colleagues wouldn't and he had a
great relationship with Muhammad Ali and
he did wonderful work and he also could
be just bombastic and ridiculous so the
first time I met him I walk up to him I
say hello mr. Cosell my my name is Bob
Costas it's a pleasure to meet you and
he says I know who you are you're the
child who rhapsodize is about the
infield fly rule I'm sure you'll have a
fine career and he flicked a cigar ash
and walked away my first thought is this
is the biggest schmuck I've ever met
and in the next second I'm thinking no
this is great because I got the full
Howard Cosell yes that was the treatment
well you you know he craved attention
apparently and and absolutely loved it
but love to pretend that it was a pain
in the ass yeah and what illustrates
that is this story his great colleague
Jim McKay they couldn't have been more
different in terms of personality McKay
the longtime host of Wide World of
Sports and the Olympics did the
wonderful sensitive job during the the
hostage crisis with the athletes in
Munich in 1972 so after an ABC event
Howard is holding forth in the lobby of
the hotel makeup still on hideous yellow
jackets still on ABC Sports exactly
exactly and McKay and his self facing
way comes through the revolving door and
is headed for the elevator when he hears
Jimmy Jimmy get over here ladies and
gentlemen there he is the diminutive and
yet highly esteemed host of ABC's Wide
World of Sports
mr. James McManus who prefers to be
known as Jim McKay
me look at this scene a scene that plays
itself out in hotel lobbies Airport
terminals restaurants city streets
across the length and breadth of this
great land of ours people who want a
moment of my time an autograph a
photograph my thoughts about sports
oh no far too mundane the larger issues
of the day I ask you Jimmy where can I
go for some sanctuary where can I find a
moment's peace and mikay looks up at him
and says Howard
may I suggest your room hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography